je voulais poser une question à nicolas
dupont aignan si le général de gaulle
avait été à votre place vous pensez
qu'ils auraient fait alliance avec le
front national au deuxième tour vous
faites allusion à un deuxième tour de la
question quand on se réfère à au
deuxième tour des élections vous allez
marine le pen serait mis derrière marine
le pen je n'en sais rien je suis pas le
général de gaulle et j'ai pas cette
pression par une question je vous dis en
tout cas ce que je sais c'est qu'à
londres
il a rassemblé des gens qui venaient des
communistes à l'action français mais ce
qu'il y avait à l'origine offert 16 qui
était bien plus à moi si je peux
répondre était bien plus adroites alors
justement verhoek ce que je veux dire
c'est quand la france est en danger
moi j'estime qu'on se serre les coudes
et qu'on défend son pays et j'ai fait
mon choix de second tour vous le
regrettez pas votre choix un instant et
je vais vous dire je le regrette pas il
ya un point où je regarde je vous dirai
après je le regrette pas parce que
aujourd'hui dans la rue plein de gens
qui viennent me voir de tout milieu de
toutes origines et qui me disent vous
avez bien raison contre macron parce que
je les fais d'abord parce qu'au bout de
premier tour j'ai défendu maison vous au
premier tour j'ai défendu mes idées au
deuxième on élimine le pire et je
maintiens et aujourd'hui les français
s'en aperçoivent que le pire c'était
macron qui est en train de bavarder la
france alors je vois tout le monde râle
et contre ma mère était tout pour eux il
y avait le son le plus immoral mais qui
est plus tard il hésite mais j'aurais de
france comment leurs alliés bonfa
qu'apporte ce n'est pas le cas de figure
on n'en sait rien devenir 2022 donc
autant le vrai conflit aujourd'hui je
suis pas le monde est content que j'ai
posé une bonne question
jean claude rich pas trop là oui mais
pourquoi le vrai conflit intérieur est
intéressant et les jarrets conflit le
vrai conflit structurel depuis le
référendum
moi mon engagement 7 et philippe séguin
ensuite maastricht ça a été de défendre
la france qui est complètement qui perd
sa démocratie parce qu'on signe des
traités qui fait qu'après on élit des
présidents qui obéissent à des gens qui
sont personne ne peut imaginer se
gainent s'allier au front national uni
alors on va pas sérieuse mais monsieur
zeribi vous n'acceptez pas que je
réponde mais ne répondre accepte pas que
vous compariez l'etrat 9,45 à 2017 quand
on compare les filets à bout quand m
voilà ce que je n'accepte pas les
endroits que vous voulez oui j'ai le
droit de faire ce que je veux donc je
reviens le vrai clivage aujourd'hui
c'est de savoir si on a un pays où le
peuple français est en démocratie c'est
à dire qu'il peut orienter les
principaux choix où ils sont décidés par
une oligarchie mondiale bruxelles les
américains etc
ça c'est le vrai problème et ensuite si
on mène une politique économique et
sociale qui profite à tous ou à une
ultra minorité est le vrai combat il est
entre mondialistes d'un côté macro qui
d'ailleurs est soutenue par les
mondialistes de gauche et de droite une
partie dlr une partie des socialistes et
de chaque côté il ya des patriotes ce
que j'appelle qui défendent une autre
idée de la france une exception
française
il y en a qui viennent de gauche
mélenchon je suis pas d'accord avec
puisque beaucoup de sujets mais il aime
la france
j'ai un brillant de mélenchon je n'ai je
ne partage pas la politique de mélenchon
mais j'arrive à les manger chez marie
doré un patriote voilà il vend pas la
france par morceau come back point c'est
tout et quand de l'autre côté ou bien
débrouillé apprend qu'il ya des
gaullistes il ya des gaullistes il ya du
front national le front national de
marine le pen et je les dis et je
l'assumé n'a rien à voir avec jean marie
le pen et je n'aurais jamais soutenu
jean marie le pen dans un deuxième tour
de présidentielle si vous voulez tout
savoir jamais d'accord en revanche faut
arrêter cette diabolisation grossesse et
je suis convaincu que ce sont les
patriotes qui gagne la prochaine
présidentielle parce que les français
on comprit l'escroquerie de macron qui
vend leur pays leur statut leur triste
de confort dans le nationalisme et le
patriote est alors grande si juste